Crime linkage is the practice of
identifying which different offenses
were committed by the same offender.
For example, if you have a whole lot of
unsolved burglaries, you want to find
out which offenses are attributable to
the same person.
That is because you might have some
information about the perpetrator from
one crime, for example, a shoe print
that points to a male with a certain
shoe size and weight.
See if you could identify which other
offenses you think are linked to that
same person.
Perhaps some of those have other
information about the burglar, such as a
witness seeing that he has a tattoo on
one hand. And in this way, you can put
together more and more pieces of the
puzzle.
You now have good reasons to believe
that the offender who is responsible for
this particular series is of a certain
gender, weight, has a certain shoe size,
which might point to his approximate
height, and he has a tattoo on one hand.
If you allocate one of those pieces to
the wrong puzzle, i.e., to the wrong
series of offenses, you unnecessarily
hinder the investigation. So, it's
important to link the right offenses to
the right person.
Crimes can be linked through the
perpetrator's MO, or modus operandi,
which is how he carries out his crimes.
This can refer to the kind of targets he
selects and what he does to those
targets.
For example, Jack the Ripper's MO was to
attack prostitutes in London's
Whitechapel area in the East End during
darkness and to cut their insides.
If another prostitute was poisoned to
death in a different part of London
during the day, that would not be
consistent with Jack's MO, and we might
therefore regard that as being the crime
of another person.
People are creatures of habit, and if we
find a way of doing something that
works, we tend to stick with that way of
doing it as we have learned that it is
effective.
A skilled burglar who knows how to pick
locks is unlikely to kick the door down.
He is much more likely to continue
picking locks as that gets him through
doors quietly. So we're looking for
commonalities in decisions taken by the
offender, how and whom he targets and
how and whom he attacks for example. We
also need to take into account
progression.
A prolific offender might gain at least
experience but perhaps also additional
skills during the commission of each
crime.
When he makes a mistake on one occasion
for example that nearly got him caught,
he might take care to avoid that or
prepare for it next time round.
As we're looking for both consistency
across time but also progression, it is
important to identify in which order the
offenses took place.
Criminals also tend to become
increasingly confident as they continue
in their offending without getting
caught. So they might be willing to take
more and more risks.
Of course, the most reliable factor to
use when linking crime is forensics so
that when you find an offender's DNA at
every burgled property, you can safely
assume he has been there.
MO is another way of linking crimes but
it is not as reliable as geography which
I will introduce next.
Thank you for watching. I hope you found
this content useful.
You can get access to each episode's
transcript with key learning points,
timestamps and references if you get
yourself onto my mailing list. Just go
to the main website on police science
doctor.com and on the bottom of each
page you will find a sign up form for
notifications of new content. Just enter
your first name, your preferred email
address and the type of organization you
work for. You will not get any spam.
This is just for me to let you know
about new content and for you to get
access to all the transcripts.